we had reached a point where it took a
loud mouth without many of the traits
that we think of as common decency to
say the simplest truth he was the man of
the moment he was the man we needed and
I voted for him twice and I vote for him
again if I have to but I think if if he
had if he had an ounce of Grace he would
say I christened DeSantis the new me and
let him go Dr Sebastian Gorka was
sitting where you're sitting
we left it exactly as it is just for you
um he's he's very big on Trump and
you've talked about
how it was a sad day that Trump had to
come along and you're not on the Trump
train now yeah that that's right I was I
said from the very beginning I think
that the two I have to say that I think
the two people who got Trump exactly
right were me and Victor Davis handsome
and I think I said it first but Victor
wrote a great book about it so he so he
wins but like but still it was that he
was a tragic figure from the start and
he was a tragic figure because the very
things that made him great also made him
wrong and also we're going to destroy
him I mean that's what tragedy is the
things that made him worth seeing and
worth supporting were ultimately going
to destroy him
I think he lost that second election I I
I said he was going to I knew he was
going to about two years in
because we had reached a point where it
took a loud mouth
without many of the traits that we think
of as common decency to say the simplest
truth
you know I mean that was the thing that
was beautiful about Donald Trump he
would say things that could easily be
interpreted as racist he was not a
racist I don't think he I don't think he
was a racist at all but he would say
things that could easily be interpreted
as right because he didn't care if they
called him races
but he also treated people badly he
fired men who deserve would you couldn't
disagree with them you can say they're
doing a bad job but he firemen who are
deserving of respect in public or he you
know it was like he pulled the rug out
from under them he called people names
he made up names which was an adolescent
thing to do it all worked you know I I
got it I under I understood it the
minute I saw the people react to it I
didn't understand it at first but the
middle I saw the people react to it I
thought oh he's speaking for them he is
the voice of the people but at the same
time he was the voice of the people he
was also this narcissistic guy without
very good manners and I think that
that's what killed him I think it'll
kill him again if he runs I think he's
the only
the only Republican who could possibly
lose to Joe Biden he might not he might
beat him but I think he's the only one
who could lose to him so you're a
DeSantis guy yeah I I like the Santos he
hasn't been tested on the national
scene you know but I really like his
fighting attitude and as Gorka will tell
you he wouldn't exist if it weren't for
Trump everything good in the Republican
party has come down from Trump he he
recreated the Republican Party the the
guts they sometimes show now which they
never did before the uh the the
unwillingness to Simply drift to the
left which they'd been doing for decades
all of that was a gift to Trump the the
big idea which somebody told me years
ago was the idea that Republicans need
to understand is you're not running
against the Democrats you're running
against the press that the press the
media the news media in this country is
the enemy of the people just like Trump
said it was he was if there was one
thing he was 100 right about it was the
news media watch I just the other day
played a montage of him taking the Press
apart I was in I couldn't stop laughing
I mean it was just it was delightful he
he was the man of the moment he was the
man we needed
um I have I have many many good things
to say about him people who say oh
you're never Trump or just line I was
the first guy at the daily wire to come
in and say I'm voting for Trump and
Shapiro yelled at me for like hours you
know like if you've ever heard the way
Shapiro talks about scene where the
Godfather where Sonny gets machine guns
[Music]
um and I voted for him twice and I vote
for him again if I have to but I think
if if he had if he had an ounce of Grace
he would say I christened DeSantis the
new me and let him go if nothing else
I'm so tired of 80 year old men running
our government you know 70 and 80 year
old men it is time for this new
generation to come along and the
sentence is good at what he does I mean
he took that state and he turned he took
he took a purple State and he turned it
into a red state by sheer competence you
know by getting it right
Trump didn't really accomplish that much
in terms of long term because he wasn't
you know people always say well he's not
a politician being a politician is a
profession you know so he couldn't get
any laws passed everything was executive
orders was all wiped Away by Joe Biden
um so yeah I think his time came I think
he was the man of the moment uh cometh
the hour cometh the man he was a gift I
always say he was a godsend but so was
King Soul you know after a while you
know your time runs out uh he was a
godsend he was he was the man of the
moment uh and I think that moment is
passed and if the Republicans can learn
what he taught them they will become a
great party
foreign